now protests have turned violent in
dozens of Iranian cities as people
continue demonstrating over the death of
a woman in a police custody a Rights
group says at least 75 people were
killed in the unrest critics accused
police of firing directly at protesters
among those arrested is FaZe hashemi the
daughter of former president hashemi
rafsanjani
well let's go live to wrestle Sardar
who's in the Iranian Capital Tehran now
rasool what's the latest on the protests
that have been taking place
well last night there have been several
protests across Iran however we can see
that they are losing the momentum in
terms of their secures the participation
to this demonstrations rallies is is is
declining but we do not know whether
this is because of the the restriction
on the internet that was put by the
government or whether it is because of
the security presence the heavy presence
of the security forces in the industry
and also their heavy-handed measures
against the against the protesters so so
far according to the official sources at
least 41 people have been killed
including the members of the security
forces as well however some of NGO says
that the real numbers are much higher
than the the numbers that are provided
by the the official sources at this
moment it's almost impossible to confirm
the real number of the casualties and
injured people we know that more than 1
200 people also have been have been
arrested detained or identified by the
security forces so far one of the most
important development that happened was
last night that the arrest of Pfizer of
sanjani who is the the the the daughter
of the former president of Iran hashimi
RAF sanjana hashemi was one of the
funding fathers of the Islamic Republic
and he was also one of the most
influential figures in the modern
history of Iran he was elected twice as
the president of the country he was
close to the revolutionary leader
Khomeini and also the current supreme
leader Ali but in the last years of his
life he has been quite critical toward
the establishment here particularly in
2009 in 2012 and then his children have
been arrested so faizer of zanjani now
is is his daughter and this is not the
first time this is the third time that
she's been arrested she's been accused
of provoking the protest us across Iran
we do not know how much is going to stay
in the jail but for the protesters
having her support having rafsanjani
family support is quite important and so
how has Iran reacted to those it says
are supporting the protests
well Iran since Saturday has carried out
several attacks particularly on the
Kurds that the Iraqi Kurdistan Regional
the regional government and that region
it's now targeting the the arm the the
the the the the Kurdish armed groups and
it says that these armed groups are
providing the protesters with weapons
they are violating Iran's Iran's border
so we have since that since yes since
Saturday so Iran started with the
artillery shellings and now it's using
the drones and even missiles targeting
these bases in the uh in the Iraqi
Kurdistan region Iraq Iran is also
accusing this the the the Kurdistan
Regional government of not fulfilling
its duties to stop the activities of
these Kurdish armed groups from the
attacks to prevent them from the attacks
against against Iran so this region the
Kurdish Regional government or that area
is in Iraq in north of Iraq are now the
basis of several Kurdish armed groups
and particularly komala party the the
Kurdistan Democratic party and the pkk
as well and we see that from time to
time both turkey and Iran they're
conducting attacks against this this
post so we do not know as of now what
are the what is the casualties the
numbers of the people whether that have
been killed or injured however here the
officials in Tehran are saying that Iran
is going to continue its attack on this
post on this uh the the the on this
basis until these groups uh stop their
activities against Iran and also stop
their supports for the protesters in
Iran live in Tehran Forest Russell soda
thank you for that update